marvel's black widow fills in natasha
romanov's backstory and along the way it
sets up plenty of juicy possibilities
for the future of the marvel cinematic
universe
the post-credits sequence in particular
ties together the stories of black widow
avengers end game the falcon and the
winter soldier
and even the upcoming hawkeye series
paving the way for a seriously involved
small screen situation
within the mcu black widow is set after
the events of 2016's captain america
civil war
and prior to those of 2018's avengers
infinity war
but the film's post-credit scene takes
viewers to an entirely different section
of the mcu's timeline after the credits
roll the extra scene of the new film
jumps forward in time to the world after
avengers end game
focusing on that sister figure yelena
balova in ohio
she's mourning that who gave her life to
secure the soul stone on vormir
during the time heist event in endgame
while elena is standing in front of
nat's grave a woman approaches her
you recognize her right valentina
allegra
defontaine actually it's contessa
valentina allegra to fountain
you may also know her as madame hydra
additionally you know her as the woman
who recruited john walker to her cause
in the falcon in the winter soldier it's
hard but i don't like to repeat myself
so you can just call me val
but don't call me val just keep it in
your head valentino is looking to set
elena on an ill-advised revenge tour
which could shake the mcu variety
confirmed back in december 2020 that
florence pugh is set to reprise her role
in the upcoming hawkeye tv show
starring jeremy renner as clin barton
and mcu newcomer hayley steinfeld as
kate bishop
clint's protege based on what val says
to elena in the post-credits sequence of
black widow
it seems likely that she won't be
showing up to help our heroes
after elena chides val for interrupting
her during her vacation
val gets straight to the point before
handing elena a tablet showing a photo
of clint barton
the contessa says maybe you'd like a
shot at the man responsible for your
sister's death
kind of a cutie don't you think it's
certainly a bit of a stretch to call
clint responsible for natasha's death
they both did everything they could to
sacrifice themselves on that mountain
top
but the concessor isn't known for being
a straight shooter we can infer from
this interaction that elena has come to
work for the contessa
much like john walker did at the end of
the falcon in the winter soldier
it seems madame hydra is amassing a team
of killers much like
general drakov's black widows a new
power player is already taking his place
in the mcu espionage world
and she might even have something to do
with the secret invasion
julia louis-dreyfus's appearance in the
black widow post-credits scene
was definitely unexpected but it wasn't
quite as surprising as it was originally
supposed to be
before the kobit 19 pandemic hit in
early 2020
louis dreyfus was set to join the mcu
during the post-credits scene of black
widow
but we all know what happened in 2020 so
goodbye original
mcu plans after reshuffling the order a
bit
valentina made her debut on the falcon
and the winter soldier
you can watch julia louis dreyfus in
both black widow and the falcon and the
winter soldier
on disney plus it's an extra 29.99 for
the movie
the series is no additional charge to
your monthly subscription
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one